ce qu'on voit dans cette vidéo là
[Musique]
c'est faux il y a plusieurs vidéos comme
celle-là qui circulent ces derniers
jours qui disent que le gouvernement
aurait lui-même allumé des feux de forêt
à la d'hélicoptère équipée de lancement
dans les images qu'on voit c'est vrai
que les gens essaient d'intensuellement
mettre le feu à une forêt mais leur but
en faisant ça c'est de protéger
l'endroit des feux de forêt et non le
contraire c'est une technique qui
s'appelle brûlage dirigée le but c'est
de brûler stratégiquement des zones
forestières pour qu'elles deviennent
essentiellement des pare-feux vu leur
manque de matériel combustibles cette
stratégie là elle peut aussi servir à
régénérer certaines plantes protéger des
plantes d'autres espèces envahissantes
ou encore favoriser la biodiversité et
la vidéo que vous avez vu elle a même
pas été tournée récemment en fait elle
date de 2020 l'AFP a réussi à retracer
la personne qui va mis en ligne la vidéo
cette année-là il y a confirmé qui était
bel et bien pompier que c'était bel et
bien un brûlage dirigé mais il y a pas
voulu dire où exactement la vidéo avait
été tournée